[Music]
in Genesis 3 the ible documents the
First Act of Witchcraft as the serpent
beguiles Adam and Eve in the Garden of
Eden Adam's response after the fall was
to hide is coming out of the new age
possible we have Pastor John lomacang to
help us unpack this question welcome
back Pastor John yes thank you so much
blessings as you posed in the
introduction and inserted the thought of
Genesis chapter 3 I think it'd be really
really good for those listen listeners
and viewers may not that may not be
aware of what Genesis 3 is all about you
know Genesis 1 and 2 pretty much talks
about the creation of the world and then
the establishment of some guidelines
that God inserted into man's existence
and he put there a tree of the knowledge
of Good and Evil and he said in Genesis
2 don't eat of it because in the day you
eat of it you will surely die now
because we talking about the occult and
the plans of Satan to cause deception
Genesis 3 brings into clear view this
controversy and how it began how the
door was opened to bring into the world
the pain and suffering we have today and
I like the fact that you talked about
the results of it what did Adam do Adam
and Eve they hid but now listen to The
Narrative Genesis 3:1 and it really fits
into the helping us understand how the
devil still works by the way before I
read it he works two ways he W he works
covertly or overtly he either deceives
or destroys there's no Third Branch he
deceives or destroys there is no Third
Branch this is
deception now the serpent was more
cunning or more subtle than any beast of
the field which the Lord God had made
and he said to the woman has God indeed
said now the reason I want to introduce
that is because uh when we talk about
the word of God the word of God is being
used today
and it's surprising that there is so
much Confusion by movements all claiming
to be following the same book but if you
notice how the first deception began the
first question that that Eve was asked
by the serpent has God indeed said in
other words are you sure God said that
so he didn't ask her tell me what God
said he said are you sure that's what
God Said so he's promoting doubt in the
mind of the believer he's promoting
doubt in the mind and so he promoted
doubt about what God had actually said
has God indeed said that you should not
eat of the tree of the garden but he
says of every tree notice how one word
changes the entire definition because it
was only one tree God said not to eat of
he says did God say really not to eat of
every tree and you'll look at the world
today and you realize that when people
begin to decline in their spirituality
they tend to whitewash I can't do
anything everything you guys do I can't
do it they whitewash it almost to make a
make it look as though
obedience is the bad thing it's the
cause of the problem it's if I if I
follow God's word I can't have any fun
right and the devil made it seem that
way in the very beginning God has kept
every tree from you you sure he said
that and Eve responded in verse two of
Genesis 3 uh we may eat of the fruit of
the
tree of the Trees of the garden but of
the fruit of the tree which is in the
midst of of the garden God has said You
shall not eat of it nor shall you touch
it lest you die
and now she's inserting her own opinion
about now she's inserting what God
didn't say he didn't say you can't touch
it he said don't eat it I'll use the
classic example you might lift you might
pick up a g of beer but don't drink it
you might hold a cigarette but don't
smoke it and in some cases don't even
touch it in reality today to today but
God didn't say don't even touch it he
said don't yes don't ingest it so many
people today are ingesting the things
that are affecting the way they think
Music Entertainment by behold we're
becoming changed what we allow to go
through the Avenues of our soul our
senses our hearing tend to shape the way
we think as a man thinketh so is he so
the door was open Romans 5:12 by Adam
what did Adam do let's look at the story
as it goes on the serpent said to the
woman you will not surely die and so the
basis of spiritualism and occultism
today is this idea of the immortal Soul
reincarnation as we see it in Hinduism
or Buddhism the many cycles as is in
Mormonism as in Buddhism well you you
get a chance to come back time as a
beetle or a bug or dog or a spider or a
cow even a rock even a rock who would
want to come back as a rock I mean a
rock is anyway let's not even go down
that road but the basis of the new age
is formulated on these ideologies and
when we think of the new age why the new
age well the one thing that the devil
knows is that there is a new age coming
mhm and he knows that this new age is
coming so he's trying to create a
counterfeit new age and let me just
share with you B some of the basics of
what's behind the New Age movement I'll
read it verbatim uh the new age is a
broad movement characterized by
alternative approaches to traditional
Western culture with an interest in
spirituality mysticism holism and
environmentalism now I you you're from
California I live in California I lived
in Northern California uh one we lived
in Northern California with no with no
negative thought to the people that you
know take special recognition of trees
in their old age you know we have trees
1,00 1500 years 2,000 3,000 years old
now I too say you shouldn't cut those
trees down but in the mindset of
spirituality not led by God or
spiritualism they looked at those trees
as uh being occupied by by God by God by
wisdom strange force and if we cut those
trees down we and this branch of wisdom
and the new age in the phrase is I want
to use here holism holism is a term that
is often used that means everything is
interconnected so we have an age that's
coming everything is going to be
interconnected interconnected to
righteousness correct so the new age
says through the Avenues of spirituality
which is spiritualism
mysticism en environmentalism we create
something called holism so you have this
movement nowadays that's why some people
are so uh they have an aversion toward
the phrase uh climate change or global
warming because some people hear it in
the holistic sense the holism ideology
well this is something that is being
used by the new ages to preserve the
Earth and then you have the distorted
view of
evangelicalism that God is sending Jesus
to live on the earth during the
Millennium so they have to get the Earth
ready so this whole new age the age of
Aquarius and it's based on so many
philosophical beliefs that exist in
certain religions today that even claim
Christianity some people are looking for
the Rapture to take place and God sets
up his kingdom on Earth during the
Thousand Years the Buddhists are looking
for their God to come the Jews are
looking for the Messiah to come and the
new ages are looking for the age of
Aquarius to be filled out here on our
Earth so something that noticed though
is that you know you you pointed to
deception you pointed in how Satan can
take truth and mix it with air and what
I'm seeing is that the new age has this
Christ Consciousness right so they're
not saying the Bible's completely wrong
they're saying Jesus is coming but this
is how he's going to present how is that
dangerous because they're distorting
something that is significantly seeming
to be innocuous but it's very dangerous
it's once again a subtle approach to
deception deception doesn't have to deny
truth all you've got to do is just twist
it a little bit every tree of the garden
just one word cause a little doubt and
then you're searching in the complete
opposite direction right it creates it
creates an opposite to what God has said
so when he said has God indeed said and
so we have people nowadays that will
look at what the Bible teaches and they
will respond to that with a but or
however that's your understanding and so
we have even in Christianity Today where
spiritualistic ideologies have been
inserted in music and places of worship
so you find some worship centers that um
their main focus is they call it worship
music but what's missing is what you
have to be concerned about where the
word of God is absent because keep in
mind in the garden of Temptation Jesus
never said it is sung he he said written
it is written amen so the devil the
chief of music he he could sing in many
many different
tones his pipes and his timbral were
created in him as we read there in
Isaiah and Ezekiel 28 talking about uh
Lucifer son of the morning a terminology
now used in the hip hop world a song
even created Lucifer son of the morning
so he uses these little slight twists
and I I may I posed the question one day
I said just imagine and I'm using a
period of 1,260 years which is how
Christianity today has been shaped by
the Dark Ages that lasted that long just
just imagine for a moment I had
1,260 years to move this this object
across the table from one side to the
next but you told me don't move it I
wouldn't be able to discern that it had
been moved I would have thought it was
there at the corner right but now let's
go step farther if I turned the lights
off for 1,260 years you wouldn't even
see me move it correct the Dark Ages
call the dark ages for a main reason the
word of God was absent so much of what
entered through the doors of
Catholicism came through the doors of
spiritualism and uh these terminologies
merged together where Revelation now
refers to that in Revelation chapter 17
and I'm introducing the spiritualistic
side of it or the biblical side it
refers to as the mother of harlots and
Abominations of the earth Revelation 17
now the Bible uses the term woman to
describe church but it says mother that
means she's not by herself so it's a
mother Church we're talking about it's a
mother Church ideology so today we have
holism uh uh cartisian science which is
a form of rationality rationalizing that
we've got to affect the whole thing to
affect any part of it and then you have
that they do it through something called
reductionism let me give you an example
you might share something with me that
is just so deep I can't understand it
and I would respond by saying you know
your thoughts are as white as snow m
well I could anybody knows that snow is
white correct but I've just simp I've
reduced a very deep thought into
something that anybody can ingest it's
white as snow or you know it's as clear
as a nose on your face but then I don't
understand what you said but my respon
with that was just clear as a nose on
your face or so so the devil is using
reductionism uh this holistic ideology
to create and now today let's just look
at some of these things just look at be
look at the many many stores that you
find whole the word whole is used Whole
Food okay right because Mother Earth is
giving us something so it sounds like
we're worshiping the created instead of
the Creator right and so you find in
many of these movements you might say
wow Mother Earth do they recognize the
Creator no they contributed to Mother
Earth not God which distorts creation
which distorts it so what what do we do
to help people see their way out of what
is New Age like how do they you know
they become worshippers of something how
what are the telltale signs that it is
of the occult or of God very simple it's
a short passage but it's powerful Isaiah
8:20 Listen to What a person is saying
to the law and to the testimony if they
speak not according to this word it's
because there is no light in them and
this word is what God's word amen so
measure everything by God's word you
know the problem in our world today is
we don't have what's called standards
that are immovable standards your
philosophy is your standard My
Philosophy is my standard that's your
truth my truth but we Collide and we
call them both truth can you imagine
giving me directions that both are
opposite and they're both true it's
impossible no navigation wouldn't be
possible yeah putting right it's like
putting two addresses in your navigation
and the navigation say which one you
want to go to and you say both both
right it it will be it will be stunted
so what's happening today we need God's
word as a reliable God
something that I see that's very common
throughout all of these other religions
is that there is a potential or a
possibility a gateway to speak with the
dead MH why is that the other basis in
the garden is in Genesis 3:4 the serpent
said to the woman you will not surely
die so if you're not dead then let's put
all the other pieces together that are
not even suggested in scripture that's
why you hear people say Well they're
they're in heaven looking down now
speaking of when their family after they
have died after they have died or you
have another phrase well they die but
their soul went to heaven and I've often
said as I've heard this terminology used
so many times and and this is the crazy
part about it you've heard of seances
and uh fortune tellers and palm readers
and uh people that say uh I'm able to
contact mediums okay this is heavy yeah
when Christians and Med mediums share
the same belief something is
wrong when a medium who is a
representative of a lie an agent of
Satan has a teaching and a practice that
I that identifies with a branch of
Christian practice something is wrong
the Bible says the dead know not
anything Ecclesiastes 9:5 the living
know that they would die but the dead
know not anything also their love their
hatred their Envy is now perish they
can't even praise never more will they
have a portion and anything done under
the sun MH but the medium say they're in
heaven I could communicate pastors are
saying they're in heaven when there's no
scripture that says they are in heaven
after they die we will be there when
Jesus comes back John 14 I will come
again to receive you to myself that
where I am there you may be also so
spiritualism merges the two together
takes a little bit of Truth they both
agree they died that's the truth mhm but
where they are is the lie and there's
the error and that's where the error
comes in so we're clear that we can't
contact the dead cannot contact the dead
and the reason why we know they cannot
contact the dead let me just put it in
very simple terms if your battery dies
on your car does it work in somebody
else's car not at all if your dog dies
you give the dog to the neighbor to run
around their yard death means death it
means the end of life not the
continuation of Life somewhere else and
so the devil has made it appear as
though you're not really dead you
haven't
you're dead but not surely and that's
the term that's used you will not surely
die so if we don't die what then happens
we are resting in the grave waiting for
the coming of the Lord that's why you
find in the scriptures in in 1
Corinthians chapter
15 uh for the trumpet shall sound and
the dead shall be raised Incorruptible
let's make it very simple people that
are watching the program undoubtedly
it's rare that somebody watching hasn't
known about a funeral haven't gone to a
funeral when you go to the funeral where
do you take the person to the cemetery
or if they were crated you have the ear
with the ashes there all communication
ceases at the point of death it doesn't
continue somewhere else but here but
here's the irony of it if you died and
went to heaven Jesus wouldn't say I'll
come back to get you he could simply say
I'll see you when you get there but very
true but we cannot go and here's the
simplest reason 1 Corinthians 15 verse
51- 5
5 for this Mortal what does that mean I
will die I can die will put on
immortality this corruptible this
decaying body will put on incorruption
I'll never Decay never die again that
change has to happen we will not all
sleep we will not all be dead when Jesus
comes but we will all be changed in the
moment in the twinkling of an eye until
that change how does this change happen
this how does it happen yeah we put on
the immortality that Christ possesses
now so we just get to put it on right
then and there or is there a process is
what I'm actually getting at the
resurrection Amen in the resurrection
for the dead in Christ shall rise first
first 1 Thessalonians chap 4: 13 to18
for the Lord himself shall descend from
heaven with a shout with the voice of
the Archangel with the trumpet of God
and the dead in Christ who arise first
now why the trumpet of God that's God
calling the dead back to life now one of
the ironies of that is when you follow
follow scripture it doesn't deny that
we're going to be in heaven it just
simply says we're not getting there on
our own not our own merits not our own
works and not on our own in our own
nature the change has to take place we
will put on incorruption we will put on
immortality and here's the facts mortal
man cannot exist in the presence of an
immortal God our God is a consuming fire
but the new age has taken this ideology
that's why you have the worship of and
if you look at all the religions today
in some facets of false religions the
dead are worshiped they are
honored they are uh uh revered there's
altars for them oh pictures and foods
and different things to uplift them and
to keep them in this unknown realm this
limbo realm that they're supposed to be
in until they're reincarnated until they
re and even still today those terms leak
into Christianity they say well my mom
is my guardian angel
yeah we have nopt for that falsehoods
and so these things are there and um
people begin to say okay well if that's
the case what's the difference between
the New Age and
Christianity and um I've seen the
differen is very Stark and very clear
one true Christianity is based on the
word of God you know John 17:17 sanctify
them by thy truth Thy word is truth
Romans 10:17 faith comes by hearing
hearing by the word of God so how can we
be
Christians without allowing God's word
to be the foundation and our guide our
guiding principle our guiding principle
so but many people will say but I've had
experiences I have seen or you know an
apparition I have heard their voice was
exactly like my father's was they knew
exactly what type of candy I liked as a
child that that was definitely my dead
dad what do you say to that the Bible
talks talks about let's put this whole
picture together how long has Satan been
around when he when he was cast out of
Heaven Revelation 12: 7:9 when he was
cast out of Heaven his angels were cast
out with him now these now are in the
Earth and there's a phrase in the Old
Testament in the book of Deuteronomy and
Leviticus Leviticus called familiar
spirits from which we get in the Hebrew
the word family now we don't see them
they are they're in a dimension that we
cannot touch taste or smell we can't see
them but they can see us and so how easy
is it in the same way that when the
angel when God sent angels to appear to
man they appeared in the form of man now
if we saw angels the way they really
exist as Ezekiel 1:2 describes them we
would think wow that's not anything I've
ever seen before so what happens is
Satan now knowing the voice of your
grandmother knowing what your
grandmother like knowing your favorite
numbers and your favorite candies will
come to you in a form of an apparition
that's why Isaiah 8:16 see Isaiah 8:19 I
want to share that with you talks about
that the basis of Isaiah 8:20 to the law
and to the testimony was based on Isaiah
8:16 and when you look at Isaiah 8 look
at what the the prohibition was I'm
going to read Isaiah
8:16 it says um bind up the testimony
seal the law among my disciples verse 19
just before Isaiah 8:20 which says to
the law and to the testimony there was a
reason that you have to test it based on
that because there were many people in
the day of Isaiah the prophet that were
looking for ways of communicating with
the dead and look at what the Bible says
and when they say to you Isaiah 8:19
seek those who are mediums and wizards
who whisper and mutter should not a
people seek their God should they seek
the dead on behalf of the living
actually makes no sense but it's not new
it's old so this new age has been around
since biblical times ever since the fall
of humanity and so we have familiar
spirits nowadays I had a young boy call
me once from Orlando Florida said sir
and I said yes he says uh my mother
visits me and I'm very upset I'm very
afraid I said why would you be afraid of
your mom she
died and I said do you talk with her yes
she talks with me yes and I told him
what to do and that never happened again
and I said that's not your mom but
here's what I recommend you do and uh he
followed my
recommendation and that Spirit never
responded and never came back to him
again these are evil spirits we can only
resist the moment we start to believe in
it we give them right in our life so
these are monitoring Spirits they're
always watching us studying us they're
monitoring spirits and they are
deceiving Spirits okay and Paul says in
the last days uh many will depart from
the faith giving heed to seducing
Spirits the new King James deceiving
spirits and doctrines of devils so we've
done a great job I think of giving the
gamut of how you can get trapped in the
New Age and what I want to do is to give
the viewer a way out if you're in the
new age is it possible for you to come
out oh yes there's always a way out the
word of God is a way out now first
somebody might say well I don't know how
to read the Bible we're not saying that
you have to read the whole Bible to find
your way out but the first thing that a
person can do and I've seen many people
do this they say Lord this is something
so humble Lord if you really do exist
guide me and that phrase that I've just
used has been the the Genesis of many
people finding freedom because the Lord
never denies the call of a humble heart
whosoever calls upon the name of the
Lord will be saved and so the Lord is
waiting he's standing at the door
knocking all the time if you open the
door I will come in if you invite the
Lord into your life all the power of the
enemy cannot break your connection to
God if you close that door the Lord says
I set before you an open door that no
man can shut Revelation Jesus in John 10
is that door if you say Lord I'm opening
the door of my heart for you to come in
you can invite the Lord into your life
and and what I love about this whole
series what's it called again wolf and
sheep's clothing ex that's exactly
what's happening today be careful when a
Shepherd even a pastor comes to and say
hey but I believe that God's word
supports the fact that you die and go to
heaven you can't find a single scripture
that supports that they'll twist it but
as in a court of law look at the
evidence of all the Bible teaches about
what happens when you die and don't take
a single scripture and build a castle on
that doesn't matter how long or how deep
or how far or how Wicked you've become
no can you still come out no Ezekiel
chapter 18 the Bible holds out a
beautiful beautiful uh invitation it
says when I say to the wicked one you
shall surely die and he repents and
turns from his Wicked way the Lord says
None of the wickedness that he has ever
done will be held against him he shall
surely live so God is Not handicapped by
duration of sin but he's enabled by the
Divinity of Salvation when we call on
the Lord he'll Deliver Us doesn't matter
if you've been in that 40 years 50 years
you could have been a witch or a warlock
you could have been a drug dealer or
person living a life of promiscuity
whatever the Avenue that held you Jesus
is the chain breaker Jesus is still the
way for Freedom amen and I I mean I
think I'm Testament to that you know I
was raised 7-Day Adventist I veered off
into the world I I sought power and
control and material things and you know
Co came God sent rebuke I was brought to
my knees and at that time I was dabbling
in everything not realizing I was
getting sucked into the new age you know
what started with seeing a spiritual
Guru you know something that he he spoke
in Christian terms I thought it was a
Christian act right and that's something
that I think is a beware you know a
message that I need to send to people
that many people will come in his name
doing things that are appearing to be in
his name but they're they're not that's
right and so what people have to do
that's are watching the program they
might say well I've done so much wrong
remember this passage first john9 how
about you let the audience know that
directly remember this passage first
John 1 19 this may represent you you
might say how can God ever forgive me
remember the passage 1 John 1:9 if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness come to the
Lord with an honest heart and say Lord I
don't need to give you my resume of evil
I don't need to say to you I've done all
this and how can you accept me he
doesn't turn away any sincere uh
invitation for forgiveness for
acceptance for Freedom From the Past he
can break the chains that have held you
and connect you to a power that will be
far greater than any power the enemy has
ever voluntarily or otherwise brought to
your life today remember this today is
the first day of the rest of your life
make a decision today today is the
accepted time today is the day of
salvation you can come to Christ today
wonderfully said thank you so much for
being here you're welcome
in the book marinaa page 60 it says the
enemy's Supreme purpose is to keep God's
created people from experiencing and
knowing that God is love but be not
afraid if you have found yourself in any
of Satan's traps for we have a Merciful
Savior who pies us is longsuffering and
quick to forgive who desires
reconciliation this has been a wolf in
sheep's clothing and it's been my great
pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]